oh yes hello John welcome John Taffer
good to see you buddy how are you oh my
god I was just watching the premiere of
Bar rescue last night what do you think
what an episode to start with you always
do always worry especially with the show
like Bar rescue like that's a show that
you at any moment you worry you could
see how that show could jump the shark
right like it starts to get hokey or
setup or whatever and I'm watching it
and like what a does that when you
walked in what a disastrous group of
people you walked into it's that's why I
keep doing it
so I start my hundred and sixtieth
episode next week Wow and what's the
reason why I do it is it is so freaking
entertaining because I'm never sure what
I'm walking into
right and Rienzi prefer probably one
it's a mess and you have something
actually do you know a good place why is
a host obviously there's low-hanging
fruit when you walk in to a place like
that there's a lot of things I can cover
you know but when you walk into a
perfect operation you don't have that
but perfect operations don't typically
they're in first place sure when I start
one from season five where it was like I
was watching it last night too it's this
lady you would have hated her Jim it's
this lady and she's just crying the
whole oh yes yes and and oh poor dear
half hours to be like look it's not even
like a typical bar rescue episode
because you're just like you just have
to leave because I have to reconstruct
your whole bar like had to redo the
floor I have to get everything new I
have to get construction bummer
you don't degrade a story though from me
from a host standpoint was an episode I
did in Orange County California with a
couple from the Dominican Republic his
name was JP her name was either at this
absolutely true and I get a one-minute
briefing before the show so I'm told
it's a husband and wife they're not
getting along while they're in debt like
400 grand she's ready to kill him she
thinks he's cheating on her etc okay get
my makeup on and get in the SUV the wife
sits down next to me in the SUV she has
a gift bag with her and I said oh what's
in a gift bag she goes oh it's a gift
from my husband it's our 14th
anniversary
like I would you get him divorce papers
Wow it's completely I remember this fine
so yeah we sit there we look at the
video monitor together and it's a couple
girls go up to her husband
hitting on they say you married he says
there's no ring on this finger and she's
watching but she set it up or how did
she get that footage
oh no we're watching it live so I'm
sitting in the SUV is now society in the
bar for like days leading oh what a dick
I just forgot the cameras are there I do
they do you know we leaving her a day
and a half and they forget it Jim it's
unbelievable and and obviously they have
to forget it because you wouldn't act
away unless your television so so we're
watching this and she goes that's it
that's it I've had it's way I talked to
her I'm gonna say listen if you're gonna
go and do this go in and be bold I got
your back this is your chance to change
it and if you saw it she goes in rips
his shirt throws a drink drink in his
face and belts him Wow today everything
a divorced so at the end of the episode
and I got at a it is at the doctor John
stop at the end of the episode they tore
up the divorce papers and about two
months later uh-huh
I got an email that they had another
baby Wow okay so I guess she was
pregnant and hopefully it was his and
confrontation therapy I call it yeah you
also worked out how long were you at the
NFL Enterprises I was on the advisory
board a benefit on appraisers for about
two years two and a half four years
Oh 95 96 right in that range I could be
a year off okay so I wanted to ask you
about the whole concussion thing there
was any talk about that back then or no
no not really you know the big issues
back there were more domestic violence
issues programming issues back then the
Dallas Cowboys was trying to do their
own logo sales right and they were
trying to step away from NFL properties
why cancer split is that there were a
huge percentage of logo sales but they
were getting a smaller distribution
because obviously it's slanted a lot of
the dollars go to Green Bay in teams
that perform less and logo sales so
there was that going on at the time it
was a pretty heavy issue so there was a
lot of pressure do you think it does a
good Commissioner no I don't and and the
reason why I don't is is a couple of
things I mean you could latch on to a
few different things but you know the
one that I latch on to the most is when
you lose control of a place I mean you
guys can't come in here and do whatever
the hell you want to do there's some
rules or some regulations you can't be
so offensive that you alienate half your
listeners right and if that we be so bad
that we
we just can't be effect yeah we yes we
can be so terrible we've lost 80% of its
selling point so what's happened is look
at the rating situation look at what's
happened you know to the brand equity to
the ratings to the cash flow so if
you're an advertiser on the NFL you'd be
pissed right now
oh yeah say you'd say that your
responsibility is to deliver me an
audience how much about is rule changes
don't like is it because that there's so
many penalties and the people figure the
game has changed a little bit and it's
gotten softer but then again the NFL's
in a weird position because they get all
these concussions happening and all
these injuries and there's a billion
dollar settle so it is it the NFL's
fault or is it just kind of people of
finding other [ __ ] to do I think I think
it's - I think Millennials are not
watching sports at the base at the level
of the generation before them did but I
also think there's something I'm going
to simplify there's so much of
likeability when when there's disrespect
of the American flag whether you like it
or you don't a certain people say I
don't like that guy for doing that when
you step out of the box of respect and
normalcy there's always a certain amount
of the population that says I don't like
that guy whether it's but then I'm not
suggesting it's right or wrong and
people can land yeah yeah yeah yeah
statistically you lose a large part of
your audience in a but you don't watch
people that you don't like so what's
happened is they've taken a game that
used to be all about plays and
strategies and they've made it about
politics and by doing so you inherently
alienate look at what happened in the
Oscars this year that terrible ratings
the greater infusion of politics to
lower the ratings right could he put on
triana board yes we want to watch
football man you know what I'm saying we
want to know these guys as football gods
right and your opinions really don't
freaking matter at the end of the day
yeah it doesn't matter what you think of
some people just want to kind of enjoy
it they don't we preach that it's an
escape man you want to watch football so
I think the infusion of politics and all
this stuff at the end of the day is very
alienating do you think I did I I don't
like udell either but I mean did
Disraeli else he could have done what
else could he have done when the
president stepped begin going you should
fire these pumps well I don't think
that's a reason to believe it but I
think I think what you do is you meet
with the Players Association you explain
listen guys if we lose audience we're
all in trouble so we have to come up
with a way for you guys to make some
kind
a statement to an event if you want off
the field you know figure this out but
during the time allotment of national
television for football we have to
understand we got to drive ratings and
as a commissioner you got to figure out
what the rule isn't stick by it right
absolutely I mean that's what that's
really what a big problem was he was
totally wishy washy on that wishy washy
on a lot of stuff you know and I think
that that's where you know he's not the
greatest and I hate him distinct yeah
but I think in that one he was in a
really tough position because it's
racial and it's like but then again if
you side with the players who a lot of
them are black then you're pissed you
off the police and all these military
that's a really shitty position of no
other sports league has had a problem
with it though no but they for some
reason none of them have I don't know
why it's because they enforce whatever
rule is there everybody knows what the
rule is and just accepts it and it's not
like this thing where it starts where
you let one guy go okay well if that's
yeah he can do that we don't really
enforce that rule well then now there's
people over here well now we are gonna
enforce it we can't now okay well that
we won't like yeah I know how to look
through each team that you don't step
out of the box either yeah you know you
stick to the rules to something right
yeah maybe this is for so when you
talking about likability is it in your
head when you're doing a bar rescue show
do you go like okay like I was really
severe because that's how this shows
always begins severe and hopefully you
get to a positive place sometimes you
don't but hopefully you do like do you
go after a day or something of shooting
do you go like okay I got it I've got to
be cool today because I got to show this
other side of me because if I'm on TV
for an hour just shouting there's gonna
be a huge population that doesn't like
me yeah you know it's interesting that
you say that cuz I've never had that
thought real while making a show ever
yeah you know I just tend to go in there
and do what I have to do and it's the
cameras disappear to me I'm not saying I
don't know they're there but they
disappear it becomes you and me so to
speak in each other's eyes putting on a
show for the camera and no I can't do
that right cuz you'll know it
mm-hm and it gets really really fake so
if I'm screaming and yelling uh-oh I'm
[ __ ] pissed
sure and and here's why I'm pissed and
you know we've sort of talked about this
and that I'm given four days to do
something would normally take me four
months right so I'm under a lot of
freaking pressure man is this clock
ticking in my head and if you're not
jumping on board I'm gonna make you
freakin jump on board so it gets heavy
for me because if you don't move
the pace I want you to I'm gonna fail
that ain't cool and it's gotta look you
have to get us how about getting permits
and all that [ __ ] like what you have to
get something built you have to lot of
times go to the city local government so
so how do you do that in four days where
do they come back and reshoot when when
they're well we have to get a filming
license right which in essence is a
movie production license because it's a
set and we have generators and five
trucks we have a crew of 57 I have car
finding carpenter tents and everything
by the way if you guys would like to
come to an episode and do recon and left
uh I would that be fine now I'd love to
do I'll have you guys do it you know you
can actually see it yourselves let's
make that happen
er lutely but but uh uh so we through
that movie licensing we have the ability
to build things on a temporary basis but
we don't leave a temporary so we know we
can create now we have to go see the
building department which we do about a
week before ok the challenge is we don't
know what we're building till I get
there a week later so the cities have to
work with a secret a set of
possibilities like it may be new
flooring it may be this but we'll we'll
uh Jim we don't do structural stuff I'm
not gonna move a structural wall I'm not
gonna move electrical because I can't do
that in 36 hours and sure and I guess so
that makes it different okay I guess the
city would want to work with you because
ideally if it's Taffer coming in and
it's gonna be on bar rescue like this is
gonna drive the economy yeah yeah and
it's funny you know it's interesting
when we come into the market one of the
first things typically happened is we
got a phone call from somebody says
listen uh you need to portray us right
you know I want you to ignore those you
know 170,000 murders that we had last
week downtown right so I mean we make
sure that we portray each community in a
positive way and and you're right they
benefit by our presence and I mean that
makes sense it doesn't really hurt the
integrity of the show cuz it's not like
it wouldn't make sense if you were like
I'm here to save this bar now this bar
is course 50% married people 70 murders
happen faster and you're like what are
you talking about my job is to make
people root for the place right do you
travel out of the country or only in the
States
uh all in the States but but I'll tell
you a secret that haven't told anybody
yet yes we realigned our entire
production schedule and we're going to
Puerto Rico next week to rescue two bars
in communities that are [ __ ] level
Wow
because of the storm and nobody's
talking about it anymore they got no
power no water so they stood on the
power
Oh Island doesn't watch so we're going
down yeah almost six months
oh my job we're going down then we're
gonna do a hurricane episode so to speak
we're gonna rescue this Barbie the first
business in this community to open Wow
we're really excited about it so when we
can steer the show to do some good
that's pretty cool yeah that'll be less
about you being like hey you're a
failure and more just like hey we're
here this is what we gotta scream to
somebody who had lost everything though
we did that here in after superstorm
sandy at the buzzer
barbaracle a similar kind of a thing
well you know they're not failures but
the storm took if this storm [ __ ]
everything else it's kind of going back
in to try to help but how it's wrong
they didn't have the money to open or
the speed to open and season was coming
so I can do it quickly sure you know in
bail amount how close have you been to
getting punched in the face because I
mean I've seen it a lot where it's like
from a from a viewer I saw the premiere
you were close to getting punched in the
face by the chef in the kitchen like has
there been a moment where you're like
you get ahead of yourself and then in
the back of your head you're like I
don't want to get a fight with this guy
right now on television I've never had
that thought either uh-huh I've had
people push we've had a little shoving
and stuff over the years and your
shuttle back oh yeah even though you
know now you're a public figure well I'm
not gonna punch somebody in the mouth
today if somebody pushes me I'm gonna
hold them back gosh you're not gonna
push him into a wall or hurt them aha
Talia certainly I'm six two and a half
yeah he's not a small man no he's no you
handle differently than I would use this
body yeah like he's got a he's got a
pressure he fell asleep in mine I came
up in a nightclub business so I've been
dealing with drunk jerks and aggressive
people my whole life I had people kind
of know you know what you're talking
even if they don't like what you're
saying they can't go this guy's never
done this they've done it and you're
there to save their business like it's
like at the end of the day yeah I am
they're requesting you be there yeah and
they might not but they you know wants
him there they really start to
understand Jim that I do care and they
see it because I'm not really fighting
with them I'm fighting for them right so
they get mad but they don't get that mad
also when I look in their faces and here
in Queens in Sunnyside Queens they did
the fireman's bar with the guy one
family and that was the closest I ever
came to getting belted who both
why and well because I was a I was
pretty much firing one of the brothers
you're you talkin me yeah I'm talking to
you we were face to face like that
classic boxers your honor
and you think I'm big a Jimmy was bigger
than me but there's lion-o a spit was
flying both ways or I'll both get in our
showers and you know as I'm looking into
his eyes which are right in front of me
I mean four inches from right
I see his pupils dilating and that's
what happens before people tend to get
violent as you'll see their pupils start
to dilate a dog and a cat
you know primates same kind of thing so
you can see it wow that's very observant
I would never notice but in that moment
do you have the the mental strength to
back away and realize the or your hands
upon where you go so I'm screaming at
Jim I'm so you know you're you're an
[ __ ] you [ __ ] this up you're
ruining it for your family Bubba are
these ready to punch me in the mouth and
then I suddenly say do you want me to
help you suddenly doesn't want to punch
me in the mouth anymore he wants to be
helped actually is that so I can steer
the conversation not because I'm really
good at this and I can diffuse it when I
want to
you're not gonna belt me in the mouth
when I'm saying you do you want me to
help you yeah cuz obviously there's a
problem with this they call you and they
ask you and it's in their heart they
know like we're about to go to business
absolutely so I can scream and yell at
them all day long and then the sentence
that way yeah and you know that's a
pretty powerful thing for them are you
married yeah but then what do you like
around the house like when you're home
are you moral are you the same way or
you just more like no more milk cuz I
don't have a clock ticking you know what
I'm saying I'm not taking a 24 hour a
day and making it an hour that's what
that freaking intensity comes from and
but if it's like if it's garbage day on
Monday and you know the next garbage
pickup is Thursday and your wife has not
put out the trash and you realize it's
Tuesday morning you don't like go are
you [ __ ] kidding me
no I make sure somebody else takes out
the trash that's probably the right
strategy and you have a book that we
should put it's called don't [ __ ]
yourself crush the excuses that are
holding you back John is doing a
assigning tomorrow at Barnes & Noble in
Las Vegas he did sign in New York last
night
yeah well that I was great man yeah came
out right
I better I need plenty of places packed
it was great that's great so you come
out in Vegas you can you can see John
tomorrow I don't know we're in Vegas I
don't know how many Barnes & Noble there
is there's no address in this but go to
John Taffer no H John Taffer calm or Jon
Taffer on Twitter
the informations there - what's the book
about you know guys I'll tell it to you
quickly this is a bit of labor of two
years to write this sucker after 120
something Bar rescues I realized one day
that nobody's ever looked at me and said
they're failing cause of me right they
always blame someone or something else
so I started to realize the common
denominator failure excuses then I took
it a step further and I said to myself
what the [ __ ] is an excuse an excuses
actually it took me months to figure
this out a reconciliation of a mistake
either you did something you shouldn't
have done you didn't do something you
should have done or you made a bad
decision or you'd never use the [ __ ]
excuse in the first place mm-hmm so then
skews excuses become the common
denominator of when we freeze and don't
do something we should so then I realize
okay if excuses are the common
denominator of failure I could change
people's lives by breaking this [ __ ]
down so I took excuses prove to you in a
book that there the paralyzing poison of
moving forward and then I picked the top
six excuses that I've seen after
hundreds of our rescues and rights
around and break them down you number
one is fear for example cuz the excuse
is you rely on the excuse like I don't
have to make you feel better yeah I
don't have to work on the problem
because it's not a problem it's this
over here is going on you wake up in the
morning and you say to yourself you know
my radio show sucks but it's it's Jim's
fault I do it a lot but as long as you
blame him you don't have to change right
but if you woke up in the morning and
say you know this show sucks cuz of me
right then you would change so that's
the whole point we deflect it yeah with
some excuse that just makes us feel
better and it's really the core of when
we fail if we can stop ourselves from
making the excuses then we're forced to
[ __ ] deal with it does it drive you
crazy because it drives me crazy when
you point out to somebody like this is
what you're doing you are doing this
like you can admit to me that you're
doing this and you know you're doing
this and you get in you get an excuse
back or whatever and you realize in that
moment like they're there in the process
right now of tuning you out completely
of course does that drive you insane
yeah and then the word but right so dude
did you put this bottle of water on the
table yesterday uh yeah but so the
excuse always
after the word but right well there's no
expression everything after but is
[ __ ] yes right that's right yeah
that's that's where the excuse yeah but
no that's right right so you saw my fear
people are afraid of uh a lot of things
afraid of spending the money afraid of
doing it afraid of not doing it fear is
the biggest one but if you think about
it
whatever somebody's scared of to do
hundreds of thousands of people already
[ __ ] dead right
so the fear is [ __ ] if you really
think about it you're scared of
something I mean you guys are in front
of a microphone with all these people
listening it's very easy to say that's
terrifying I'm not gonna do that but you
did and that's the point so fear is BS
public speaking fear is BS all of it is
the next one is a great one is time I'm
at a time what a crock of [ __ ] that is
if it was important to you you would
have done it right of course
so it isn't that you're out of time is
that you blew it off right so let's just
understand the way that is you'd stay up
an extra hour at night if it was that
important right you know the other one
is ego I love this one you ever noticed
the guys with the biggest ego have the
thinnest [ __ ] wowit's I haven't
noticed that but I've noticed that the -
the biggest egos have other flaws right
right so you know so that's a really big
one the other one is is a knowledge oh I
don't know enough to do this poor I know
so much that I won't [ __ ] listen
anybody else right knows I know at all
are these the things that stop people
from taking first steps towards what
they want to do or that stop them in
their tracks or all of the above all the
above yeah you know if you want to do
something in your life and you come up
with excuse that causes you not to do it
then why why did you want to do it right
if you want to do it then you got to get
rid of the excuses and do it I mean
every excuse stops you from doing what
you want to do or you wouldn't use the
excuse it is amazing what an easy time
people generally have figuring out
everything that could go wrong or every
reason why they shouldn't or ever it
like that's very easy for a lot of
people to do it is you and be here if
you did it right right yeah because I
mean it is you just go like yeah of
course all that stuff but who cares but
that's an easy place to land yeah and
it's tough to say I'm not gonna be
scared I'm gonna go forward and do this
and
you know it's not easy but if you're
conscious about it you also have to put
yourself out you got a better shot I
think I think also you have to put
yourself out there when you want to do
something and now the world or
whatever's around you knows that you
want to do that and I think that a lot
of people don't do stuff because they
don't want to admit to themselves that
this is what they want they might fail
and have other people see that failure
right yes sometimes it's better just not
to try something than it is to put in
the effort and fail because you can
always live in the dream of someday I'll
do it but if you try it and fail that
little dream goes away
so how about this if you look back five
years or more in your life that that's
true I know stop achill I'm you're
saying that's why people don't try
sometimes fear [ __ ] everything and run
we go all day I shut myself to movie
lines no but I can't place them you know
that's not a movie that's true I'm
delivering it like an [ __ ]
true people do have that little fear you
know what that is that's Jim with a
moment of true philosophy that he felt
but he feared coming across like a
douche bag so he delivered it like an
[ __ ]
yeah sure distinct difference you're an
[ __ ] douche bag is more natural and
[Laughter]
forthright that's actually a great point
I've noticed that people get scared of I
think people like the idea of somebody
doing something it's scary too because
once you like yes everyone likes to have
that little daydream of whether can I
get that with people a standard bullet
time oh I should have done that I should
have and then it's like I know that it
wasn't just you're afraid of bombing
it's you're afraid of realizing you'll
never do it and you can no longer go to
that little place anymore than I think
but maybe sucking life you'd rather have
a no because then you can go on yeah go
do something fear you're stuck forever
yeah so you know that comedian who's in
maybe mode is never gonna get anywhere
no you just got to kind of try it
neither if you flop or you do well it's
the same with anything but you got to go
for it Jim Carrey and he did I think he
he talked about it in his documentary on
Netflix but he had he Kaufman wound up
that's a great it was really good yeah
but he also talked about it in a speech
that he did at one of these universities
when he gave the commencement
and he said like the best lesson in his
life was watching his father give up his
dream to raise his family and then get
laid off because this thing clicked in
like oh my god like you can fail at
doing what you don't want to be do so
you might as well fail at what you want
to be doing that's really profound yeah
yeah you can fail doing something you
don't want to do yeah that is a really
good point yeah this is what was his
father's dream but to kill his family
sort of I had a revelation like that
when I was younger when I started doing
my TV show and Canada it shut down two
or three times because of me wait why'd
you say when I started doing my
television show productions shut down
two or three times because of me because
I refused to fake anything
and production likes to know what is
gonna happen so the other one at least
fake but they want a stage and cause and
stimmy I like to go in real sure so you
know I refuse to do table reads and I
refuse to do the things that you know
other reality stars required to do and I
realized at that time that I wanted to
go down my way I didn't want to fail
because of the choices somebody else
made right yes and that was really
powerful to me it's almost the same kind
of a revelation that you come up with
life and after that point then I've
never let control of anything go and I
feel that if I fail I'm gonna fail cuz
of me right and that I can deal with
sure
failing coz is somebody else I can't
deal with do you have any editing
control and also are there things that
they've taken out that you thought
should have been left in or vice versa
yeah but I get a type of a wonderful
relationship with the network I'm you
guys are my buddies and so you know I
review all the cuts oh you do oh yeah
and remember they only see the cuts
because they're never on set I mean you
don't show on the network right now are
you we are yeah because Spike TV will
and it really came that Spike TV became
paramount Network yeah and I'm like
looking at the app and like what shows
are on and they have a couple shows that
are you know from Spike TV and
everything but I was like yeah Bar
rescue has become the biggest show on
the network yeah we have become but what
but uh not closeness I have with the
network and trust after 159 episodes
they don't bother me they let us do our
thing and they allow me to keep it real
and we've learned that
wouldn't made it this far if it was fake
people aren't stupid they're freaking
now yeah people can sense and they call
it a lot of times assisted reality but
this is different cuz it's a new cast
every week it's it's correct people
that's correct then sometimes they'll
overact discussed oh no that's their
doing you know what I'm saying you know
that and they'll do that on camera but
the reality of it is it you know it's
all real to me so what do you do when
you go in I think about this when I was
watching the premiere of this season
because to me the guy like is a drunk
and you walk in on this guy and he's
pissed at you and he's like he shoves
his wife and kid out of the way and like
that's almost getting to this place like
what was this beyond a bar rescue show
that's but he doesn't remember it the
next day I'm like this guy's an alcohol
like that's what how I saw and I'm going
like what do you do when you realize
you're way beyond the realm of hey suck
it up you know get [ __ ] together and
let's get on track and you're like oh
this this person might be suffering from
alcoholism like this is that's happened
maybe at 12 times uh-huh out of them in
all cases either you've seen it on
camera or we do it off camera we've
gotten some kind of counseling oh really
and we've brought counselors in and
actually had it you know be a segment of
the show but yeah we do that or we move
them out of that management structure
right and in the case of last week we
had him working behind a bar right and
he wasn't drinking all of a sudden he's
not drinking anything good he had
purpose yeah yeah so you tell him sir we
believe that you're a drunkard and we
believe your drunkenness is interfering
with this business operation margin
thing about a bar restaurant is that
that you got a fee Who am I fighting for
sometimes the owners an [ __ ] right
I'm fighting for his wife or his kids at
home sometimes you know I'm fighting for
the employees sometimes I'm fighting for
one partner over another I gotta have
something to fight for a while I'm there
at the end of they usually grateful or
are there any of them who like are just
ungrateful pricks or most of them
grateful Oh far most of grateful you
know maybe 10% orange huh when you're
watching you get this experience where
you watching Bart rescue like you know
usually if they're gonna be an [ __ ]
the whole show they're an [ __ ] in
segments too like by segments too you
know it yeah by the next morning by the
morning after if they're not at least
kind of cool then you're in for
something but like they're these moments
when you're watching when they're
[ __ ] the whole time boy do you root
against them and you
your clock and it's like 4550 minutes
after the hour and John hasn't started
construction yet and you're like he's
not constructed at this time walking out
on them and you're just waiting for that
moment when John's like goodbye and he
leaves see you say that when they're
being too difficult you're like we're
done we're done well I've walked out a
couple of times one of my favorite
though is when we did the dugout bar up
a block from Wrigley Field in Chicago
about a week before the World Series
last year two years and this owner was
such an [ __ ] that during the stress
test I only gave him one responsibility
during the hour and a half of distress
that's all you have to do is smile once
and the guy couldn't do it just a
complete dick and I called him smile and
Ed throughout the episode and at the end
of the episode he was such a jerk that
all of his employees wanted to quit so I
revealed the bar to his employees let
them all see it without him and I had
him come an hour later when he showed up
the employees had already seen it the
employees threw the keys at him in all
left and he had a beautifully remodeled
bar I turned it into the sports room a
press box and but he had no employees
and the reason why is I was a block from
Wrigley Field the week before the World
Series the city Chicago knew I was there
I had to remodel the bar but I wouldn't
open it for this [ __ ] so we threw the
keys and walked away Wow so easy Steve
really was a dick he was a complaint
about arrogant nothing it was his fault
belligerent entitled disrespectful to
everyone around them you know it means
you it's like trying to see where this
guy is somebody who just disrespectful
to everyone around call the press box
throw the rest box in Chicago box in
Chicago so did you and that's legit so
do you now help those other people find
other bar gigs and stuff around Chicago
well yeah I don't want to over interfere
right because you know it's between them
and their employer but you know they can
go tell of their experience and that
they were trained by us and that tends
to help yes that him Yeah right there
next time on your left that folks is
smiling it is do that has anybody ever
tried to sue you over how they're
portrayed on the show oh no not really
they probably sign away all that
some [ __ ] with the network over the
years rough but but now you guys are
obviously I mean you take care of
yourself yeah oh and it's not so I just
didn't speak to people properly mm-hmm
oh no he was a disrespectful son of a
[ __ ] I mean he make you feel two inches
tall I mean he spoke to his employees
and stuff just a real freaking ass so is
the bar still there I believe the bar is
still there yeah oh my god I love this
there's two people on the phone right
now and this is how you know you have a
clan what don't without looking at the
phone screen do you know what you're
like cuz it's in my head
have you said what's the classic episode
of bar rescue I would have the same
answers there's two people on the phone
do you know what one it is
pirates that's it you've got it I don't
know the worst week of my life man that
was it's you know wife's incredible and
I won't spoil it because we'll probably
get into it in these stories but the
it's my favorite you know that they do
text at the end of the episode they do
it reveal the new bar blah blah blah and
then they do text of how the bar is
doing it almost every single time it's
food and drink are up 20% attendance is
up this percent like almost every time
it's good news the pirate bar was just
um the text at the end of the episode
was just amazed I don't remember what it
said what did it say it's so so John
goes into this pirate part right and
he's like this is insane like they're
doing no business but they're all acting
like pirates there's no customers in
there hey matey but they're all acting
like pirates and they're insisting and
John goes we'll first you have to get
rid of this theme like you can't do
nothing pirates a good theme for
restaurant nothing not in a Maryland
right in may downtown and maybe st.
Petersburg Florida and it was like it
was like oh it wasn't like fun like
young pirate see there's like older
people in they were just doing this
pirate thing and but this was deep
though Jim these people were pirates 24
hours a day right when I put them in
civilian classes they could not speak
non pirate right right and so and so
they're they're they're they're going
through this and half the episode it
takes John arguing that they can't be
pirates anymore and they're arguing that
they should be pirates and they go and
they go and they go finally we get to
the end of the episode they're not
pirates anymore John goes in he redoes
the whole bar all these new people are
coming in you think it's a happy end
and then the text comes up on the screen
that says two weeks later they turned it
back into a pirate bar oh you burned the
sign yeah they've had a YouTube video
them sitting around the fire burning the
sign and cursing me in pirate can we see
that I want to see him being Kirsten but
why would they met with a family they
just were pirates 24 hours a day all
they wanted to be was pirates yeah they
were I know it's a hard thing to
conceive but it was true they wanted to
be piracy yeah and they were they were
offended they were offended that Jon
came in and thought that that was not a
good business
I want to hear someone talking pirate
just burn how they really say that an ex
lady
yeah they spoke yes but they had this
accent of like the 1800s and when you'd
go cuz I would do not look in their cars
in the parking lot all they had was
pirate clothes oh my god I mean it was
really more a pirate it was like it was
like a Pirates of the Caribbean pirates
like a Disney ride or like a cheap
version yep yeah and then Tracy and and
her husband a juciano
came in to back to the bar episode with
me later on and they opened a bar in
Florida now called bar Rekluse or
something but I've actually heard from
them and we've kissed and made up since
good pirate people the pirate people but
the new bar is not a pirate bar the
Florida Bar is not I have no idea you
don't even want to know let me hear
talking pirate they tell me pirate
reality
the top of his lungs of people who
aren't dressed up his presence you dress
like a six-year-old child now this was a
gentleman named Mike stop talking like
he's angry he's angry Jim that's not his
real eye extension no it's not
[Laughter]
it was a strange for you to watch
imagine what it was like for me to live
it man looking around like waiting for
the other shoe to drop like this maybe
like a put on or but one-eyed Mike who
had the patch really had one I sure and
you want to know how he lost his eye
playing pirate in a sword fight tell you
the truth you can't make this [ __ ] up so
that was you said it me episode yeah but
he lost his eye playing pirate in a
sword fight on my hub how old as an
adult don't Jim what a silly question
now what are you doing could you like a
look a the restaurant it's not just
dingy and rundown but then the back bar
like the office area is all shitty do
you work on that or only where the
people are gonna see it
no we work 36 hours so you know we can't
do it we focus on the customer areas and
the kitchen oh I mean you should see
these kitchens like we spend oh my have
you seen roaches in these places
roaches one of my cooks or one of my
chefs was in an episode in Florida and a
rat ran into his foot as he stayed looks
down is a rat next to his foot so I put
a GoPro cameras underneath the cooking
equipment and left it overnight into a
rat's running all over the place long
they want you to put GoPros under there
I think but they were not happy about
that I'm sure they weren't happy but it
was another one
we had a raccoon in the ceiling I
remember that and the raccoon was up in
the drop ceiling I live hitting all over
the freakin bar and you see it like you
see the [ __ ] and John just goes what's
that and the reveal is that there's a
raccoon that lives in the ceiling of the
bar where there's a kitchen and they
serve food so how did how did you get
the raccoon to stop going duty all over
the tree had to get exterminators in you
know to deal with the rain I thought to
do that while there's an animal no
obviously not and then the issue is
raccoons you can't just kill a raccoon
you get you got to put it back in the
way yeah this is the whole process of
you know you got to get the right guy
you just kind of put your hand up and
he'll come on down I think they're
pretty nasty oh yeah
do you and you do you kind of get an
inkling when you're in a kitchen in the
middle of the day with the lights on and
a rat is brazen enough to walk out and
touch your foot do you kind of get a
feeling that there might be a few more
oh yeah you're without a doubt you're on
their turf now obviously you gotta
exterminate but then you have to seal a
seal up all the little holes for the
areas basically we have to move every
piece of equipment or a new wall panel
and you bet you know if you hate the
place it's a food operation so you see a
lot of places that were roach infested
oh yes dude he's been there's like
larvae in the ice in these bars that he
goes to in the bottles in the bottle you
all the bottle of alcohol that they're
serving soda guns what is it that
[ __ ] flies go in there and drop their
eggs yeah because they they go to they
go to a sugar and there's fruit flies
everywhere and then is cockroach how
precise these bottles you can actually
see the carcasses and these bars have
been serving it for lord knows how long
they've been using those bottles right
and they don't even look they don't
notice
well they don't care if they see I will
yeah well that's what yes so that's why
they're failing what is the best way for
people to keep cockroaches and fruit
flies off their [ __ ] I mean with the
[ __ ] up man clean it every day you know
they're they're not attracted to
cleanliness you seen dude the premiere
episode the thing that skeeved me out
was there's like a big cutting board in
the back
I hate those two Oh guys I think he
knows where you're going he takes his
knife and he just starts scraping along
the whole top of it and this
thick layer of yellow of just a cutting
board that is never washed and there's
rot chicken put on every Akane man it's
disgusting it's great there was there
was black mold on the cutting board then
they take raw chicken they cut it and
then they put cooked chicken right back
with the raw chicken was sure and then
they pick up raw chicken with their
hands and then they pick up lettuce and
put in your salad with your hands you're
eating raw chicken but it can kill you
man I said he said because this kitchen
isn't gonna make someone sick this
kitchen is gonna kill someone and it
could good so what did you make him do
get rid of all that [ __ ] I mean that
night he cleaned his kitchen and then
you know you don't see on TV is I make
them clean the entire kitchen I make
them work all night long and then at
about 6:00 in the morning I have a
cleanup crew arrive and after they've
worked and proven to me that they'll do
it then I make sure it's clean right
with with a cleaning clean a better job
there's always something extra to do
because I'm oh he only has five six
hours you know I hear at 11:00 but you
know I want to make him do it and as I
tell them I want you to wallow in the
grease because it's [ __ ] yours yeah
yeah so I forced them to do it and get
dirty and disgusting but at the end of
the night I got to make sure it's right
so I said Mike you have people that
travel with you or you get a local crow
I have a crew 57 to travel with me I
mean how many in the cleaning crew or
cleaning crews local contractors LPAs
and stuff that'll do it too but we bring
in typically a professional cleaning
company to do the kitchens okay so they
have to move everything and just get it
and steam clean everything and I got
stuff you know how you clean equipment
you steam clean it depends upon what
piece of equipment it is but sometimes
you steam clean other times you can
damage it if you steam clean it let's go
to you want to go to line three there
this is a good one to Nick in Detroit
sure hey Nick anybody hi John I want to
ask you a question you did an episode in
Dearborn Michigan I live not too far
from there called six on dick asleep
that Jimmy would hang out it it
certainly is well chicks with dicks
probably that place was going to fail
because that place is a freaking room
staff yeah you know there was no
question I know when I leave you know we
have a business independent website
called bar rescue updates attracts us
and they have a [ __ ] about us
seventy percent success factor which I'm
proud of yeah so I have no issue talking
about the other 30% honestly when I walk
out I know most of the time if they're
gonna fail and I II just see it in their
attitudes but dude that place didn't
have a shot I thought what I created was
sort of fun they could have created a
fun a high-energy topless bar but my
guess is they didn't go with it at all
yeah I mean that's what although John
won't let go he doesn't go in with any
like moral this is distasteful this is
what he looks at the community he looks
at what the what's gonna work in the
building and if if a topless bar is the
way to go let's do a topless bar if it's
gonna be a and that was a no bar let's
do a metal bar listen I'm gonna be right
across the street from a huge auto plant
than an industrial area you know if
that's what was the right concept for it
and that's what we did we tried to do it
right though all right thanks Nikki
thank you
yeah yeah I've been - I've been to one
of the bars that got rescued I ended up
going in New Orleans spirits on Bourbon
yeah that was the - not know what -
knowledge why do you say it like
normally I said so so you know that the
chair in a spirits on Bourbon I'm told
now by the tourism associations the
second most photographed thing number
really yeah why well I created this bar
and the biggest challenge that I have is
everyone with Kevin and Maria Menounos
oh well there ya there were my dear
friends you know that yes of course so
um I had to create this bar gym and and
you know what concept do you do so I
asked my team to go on the internet and
find the history of this building is 300
years old and I find out it was owned by
a barber who had a wife and like six
girlfriends and one of the six
girlfriends killed him in the building
so from that I created his name was
Edward du Bois from that I created
spirits on Bourbon the barbershop chair
because I was a barber and the
resurrection cocktail and they sell
16,000 resurrection cocktails a month
Wow and they go through about six or
seven liters of alcohol in that barber
shop chair every night so people who
sits in a chair just who if it's open
someone it drops low you know if you're
a guy there's there's a well-endowed
female who will pour the shot directly
into your mouth when she lays you back
on the chair oh okay and there's a guy
who will do it for girls and it's a
whole thing you know you take your shot
and you get a photograph in the chair on
Bourbon Street so it's popular now it
really popular yeah yeah what a great
idea to invest how old was the building
build was about two or three hundred
years old
held a hundred years ago 150 years ago
but it was an old story that we found in
the building but all you need is one
little thread like that sure take that
one little tidbit and turn all concept
around it yeah because you kids like
what else do you do with it okay let's
find something that was really hair here
you're an assister they tell how do
people know what that story is they ask
about it
well yeah we yes they can ask about it
but the resurrection character what does
that come from well you know we're
hopefully Edward du Bois gets
resurrected you know he's the barber who
and it all connects and it's this
interesting story it's amazing when you
watch how many people just have no clue
about the business that they're in at
all like they just opened a bar they
started it on a lark or whatever it was
like there's one I was watching where
there where John's going okay what's the
rent on this place and the lady goes
like four grand or whatever and he goes
okay well in order to make money in the
bar business you need to make ten times
your rent good memory and she's like a
month and he's like yes you need to be
making $40,000 a month that's right and
she goes oh and she looks kind of
panicked and he goes why how much do you
bring him in a month and she goes like
$18,000 that's not good you know product
you know liquor is 20 25 percent waiver
is 30 percent so if you don't do ten
times your rent the numbers don't work
right so it's very easy to say you know
what is the rent in a bar I got to do
ten times that every month and when they
look at that number you know it can be
quite intimidating yes so far away from
me what are the most successful two in
the country I thought one of them is
it's a gay place on Santa Monica called
the abbey of a summit um he's the most
successful bar in the country and the
second is Jimmy Buffett's place in
Margaritaville in Vegas I disagree with
both oh okay then you know I used to run
a nightclub and bar convention to Vegas
and we always had to hop top 100 list
and I'll tell you approximate numbers uh
uh excess in Las Vegas a twin will do
about seventy million dollars this year
as a bar as a bar nightclub Buffett will
do about 34 so what that marquee in Las
Vegas this year we'll probably do 80
million which is almost tripling what
Buffett's doing so you know a Hakkasan
will come in at about 60 million in
Vegas so the highest producing beverage
operations in the world are typically
those three and
and very few cities can touch them now
you know there's a marquee here in New
York because everyone drinks in Venice
but it doesn't do at all the numbers
show Marquis in Vegas well you're
vacationing there you're going out doing
shows you're gambling it unloaded it's
okay whatever you're gonna do you're
gonna do more of in Vegas yeah I said
I'm gonna drink more party more look
more everything
hey the most successful bars in the
world to be in Vegas they do here does
that mean Vegas is a good place to open
a bar or are they kind of getting them
well it is theirs it's competitive ya
know when we open two one on Bourbon
Street there's fifty seven bars in three
blocks they closed all the time people
think you open the bar on Bourbon Street
it's so it's really competitive even
though there's a lot of people there
there's a lot of great competition so
you don't know what you're doing in
those markets right and Mardi Gras is
only for a short period of time it's
that's correct only a few days a year
that's right not the entire year and I
guess what wins amazing though I mean
despite his personal troubles like
that's a great hotel and it's new what
is it eight years old tears oh that's a
beautiful property and you know I was
sad to see all that happen cuz he was a
great developer and he was very
philanthropic in Las Vegas
are they still building there as rapidly
cuz I know for a while they slowed down
and liked it what happened romantic city
like Atlantic City is just awful like
they had the rebbe of the Ravello revel
what its calls just standing there yeah
you know Atlantic City you know when
they built that they they probably
should have put a little parentheses
under the word Caesars Palace and put
like yeah Chris you know the Caesars
Palace in Atlantic City is nothing like
the Caesars Palace in Las Vegas it's
just a very different marketplace and
then you look at Mohegan Sun you know
who's really taking their business away
with an amazing facility Foxwoods where
I'll be this was our night entertainment
facility and you know they take that
business away from surgeries got some
serious competition yeah well you know
what it was only legal there in Vegas
and now New York's talking about doing
it I mean there's stupid not to have it
in Manhattan they're giving away
millions of dollars which could help
[ __ ] alleviate everyone's taxes let's
let people just gamble
I'm sure that's what they're gonna do
with the money when they put gambling
and that's what they're gonna do Jim
they're gonna alleviate your taxes with
all that yeah that was that thank you
point that was very little in your
boyish of me that's how it works I
really I'm stupid [ __ ] naive idiot
I'm fitting
what's it like to be to have this kind
of fame at this point in your life
because for a long time you're super not
you general you're still when you're
still you're still grabbed that's what
you meant my mediocre level yeah worked
so hard and achieve so little so like
you know you've been successful in
business for a long time and so people
in that world know you but this is a
totally different thing I mean you know
this is this is the year your face is
everywhere and when I say that bar
rescue is the biggest show on paramount
Network it's also because it's on all
the time yeah so lakes month marathons
on Sunday right right Oh trust me I know
so what is it like now does it affect
business is it more difficult on a
personal level to not be able to kind of
walk around and anima Slee well that's
an issue and yeah I'm a little
uncomfortable celebrity to be honest
with you mm-hmm you know being in radio
you guys would get noticed quite as much
as TV not even here you know and I did a
project with Sheryl Crow we was standing
on a street corner everybody's driving
by screaming my name and I was a little
embarrassed by the rally and she cuz you
know it's really interesting people know
my music but they know your face right
you know there's just a difference and
so you know celebrity is a little
strange when it comes to your weight and
life unit used to it but this particular
week has blown me away I'm gonna cover
of Entrepreneur Magazine there's a big
freaking deal yeah season six of bar
rescue premiered last week and my book
came out two days ago like whose face is
on the cover of that book my face that's
a face is it's a great face don't
[ __ ] yourself it's called just to
promote tomorrow he's doing a signing in
Las Vegas if you want to go see him at
Barnes & Noble thanks to him and two
days ago he did an episode of dr. Phil
with dr. Foster held that book up and
said everybody in America should buy it
which is a big deal because he doesn't
do that very often
as a guy I've always wondered about dr.
focus sometimes he seems like he's a
legit dude and then other times he seems
like he's just trying to capitalize off
something well in full disclosure I must
tell you is my friend mm-hmm and I'm
actually having lunch with him today
well that's even then you're even more
of a person with the knowledge well he's
a friend and I'm gonna tell you he's
he's one of the greatest guys I know
really with you one of the greatest guys
I know does he do you think there is
that part of him like you know not to
take anything away from what he does but
that that carnival barker part of him
where he's putting on a show and he's
like oh this person is gonna make great
TV let's suck the great
out of him so are you gonna bring
somebody in there who does shitty radio
Oh every time each other what we do of
course I mean what's our job once we get
in front of the cameras to tell
compelling stories right so you know we
can say this guy's gonna make great TV
you know I would I would I think he's
gonna probably use a term this is a
compelling story mm-hmm you know and I
think he's looking at it that way for
that you have to you because if even if
it's just helping people and it sucks on
TV that it's gonna bomb and the
network's not gonna keep it right I mean
I mean America's Most Wanted John
Walsh's show you're never gonna do a
more valuable show than that and they
let it go because the ratings weren't
quite what they want it was somebody
else for it and they canceled him he was
literally trying to catch people who
kill kids and like dad she's not doing
the numbers you know so they wound up
bringing it back in some other or they
changed it a little bit but it doesn't
matter how noble your show is right they
don't like the numbers right [ __ ] them
thanks Robby that's a busy Fermi's he's
a machine
he's a daytime monster in television
ratings and there's a reason why yeah
yeah do you look at guys like is that
why you a guy like you just keeps
working and working and working because
you know these bar rescue shows I think
I think I've talked to you about this
last time we talked if you watch them
there's a lot more production elements
to them than an average reality show
like there is a lot put into each
episode I mean I'm and I'm just sitting
there like you spend a lot of money
right and even jail again it takes time
and like there's like you know things
and you do so you did 160 episodes so
more like there's a ton of these
episodes you're putting out books you've
also got business that's not in TV like
it's a lot
it is a lot right now we're developing a
huge Resort in Pigeon Forge Tennessee on
a whole mountain with attractions and to
hotels and restaurants convention
facilities rides and amusements we're
reinventing the customer experience and
the largest hardware chain America Gees
and doing a bunch of other things so is
that like you do you look at guys like
dr. Phil and you look at people like
having a Maria and go like this is what
we do we just keep going keep going keep
going and that does that motivate you to
keep going absolutely yeah because it's
a challenge and it's fun right projects
are fun right Tennessee's Network Dali
land is about a mile away you bet
Dollywood
Dollywood sorry yeah I uh you know we're
all big Dolly Parton fans at heart let's
be really honest I'm a fan how can you
not be of course let me tell you
something interesting she's the war
just employer in that County in
Tennessee hey she because of Dollywood
because it not only Dollywood she has
attractions hotels Dollywood her
Stampede which is a dinner theatre kind
of a concept when she is a unbelievable
employer and people who love her when
you said Dolly Parton and largest I
didn't think you were going with
employees after that no bust young lady
I've noticed she's yeah she's great
what is Dollywood Holiday Park yeah yes
it's Dolly Parton's theme park yeah and
it's popular fur
yeah it's right I notice it's yeah it's
in Tennessee it's a little bit outside
of Nashville like it's a it's in its own
area but yeah closer to Knoxville yeah
I've been to Nashville I'd never been in
Nashville I want to go there and I want
to go see Yakov Smirnoff's place we've
talked about that we're in Francis
Branson yeah have you been to Branson
I've not been to Branson I play a funny
story I many years ago I worked in
Grossinger's in the Catskill Mountains
which was a resort right and spin-off
worked there he was a waiter oh really
yeah that before he did comedy yes Wow
and remember all that all the cats go
comedians would come up there who do I
that's got me in the 70s right that was
in know AAA 79 80 81 in my range but we
had all the Casio comics coming up there
all the time I don't think I know any
was yes well I think you guys that are
mainstream or no other guys not they're
older now you know all those cats go
comedians but guys like Buddy Hackett oh
yeah you know Freddie Roman yeah now see
Lawrence you know I never got to go to
Dollywood but I did when I was a kid a
few times I went to Opryland you know
Opryland that's horse that's the theme
park right outside where the Grand Ole
Opry was and it's gone now it's gone the
Grand Ole Opry is gone or the theme
parks that's their amazing place right
the Opryland the dayward property but
least important yeah Opryland
everything's gone but it was wait you
mean the theme park theme parks you're
not the actual place the Opera House is
the theme park right okay yeah yeah yeah
but the place they sing is that Grand
Old Opry do you want to operate you
wanna go to line three there that's sure
Chuck in Boston hello how are you all
right I just wanna know that just show
that whoever pays you to go make these
bars over
once they're more successful - - oh boy
you personally profit from the success
on a you know monetarily no we have no
financial connection to them whatsoever
you know you don't take an owner stick
owner no and they don't owe us anything
you know we we sign everything over to
them that we gave them and now we leave
this is all just for you it's a one-time
interaction and at the end of it you
both done they own the rail and you own
the footage and we go to the next one
because their other reality shows like I
watch what's it called the Prophet on
MSNBC and I always think it's funny cuz
that guy takes a much more he doesn't
yell you know what I mean and he's not
like he's not in your face and
everything but what he does do is like
the whole premise of the show is he gets
these businesses back on their feet but
he takes like 50% of the business like
that's the whole putting money in you
guys are putting money into and they
really take no percentage though we just
give it to you right it's a gift it is a
gift technically sounds like a silly
question but if you're doing in 36 or 48
hours is this stuff trend of how long
construction takes is is the stuff
constructed as I mean obviously it's
gonna be but how they do it as well as
it should be done of it so fast to rip
stuff out takes a while put [ __ ] in
takes a while it's it's it's the quality
of the materials that you use you know
if you do stone on a wall at ain't going
anywhere right if you put cheap paneling
on a wall people gonna push their pens
through it right so I got to use the
right materials but that's years of
doing this Jim Ian so you know the bars
my whole life so these are commercial
construction projects not built like
home extreme makeovers right now you're
not building it like your bedroom in the
house